[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, hi, folks.
Laci Green here.
Let's watch a movie!
I watch documentaries a lot.
Thanks to a huge selection that
I have on my Netflix account.
Netflix is pretty amazing.
It give you access
to TV and movies
through the internet machine.
So check it out,
netflix.com/dnews to try it out
for a month of free streaming.
And let me know what
documentaries you're watching.
Last night I watched
(A)sexual, which
is a documentary that I've been
meaning to watch for a while
now.
Because I've heard
great things about it.
And it worked with a
few people in the film.
Overall, I really
enjoyed this film.
Asexuality is pretty
misunderstood.
Sexual people hear about
it and they're like, what?
You don't like sex?
At all?
That's crazy!
But it's a real sexual, or
rather asexual orientation.
About 1% of the
world is asexual.
These are people who don't
experience sexual attraction.
Period.
They don't want to
have sex with anyone.
A good chunk of the
film follows David Jay,
who was openly asexual and
was one of the first activists
to try to organize
asexuals online.
He's been really outspoken, he's
been on TV a number of times,
raising awareness, and giving
asexuals a place to belong.
Before the internet,
there really
wasn't a great way to connect
to such a small community.
And a lot of people
felt-- and many
continue to feel-- like there's
something wrong with them.
They don't experience
sexual attraction.
Meanwhile, the entire world
is preoccupied with sex.
I mean I can imagine
that could make
a person feel like
a real outsider.
And it doesn't help that
asexuality apparently
makes people really
uncomfortable, confused,
and even angry.
There's one scene where
the asexuality group visits
San Francisco Pride, the
bastion of love, tolerance,
and acceptance, right?
Nope!
It was shocking to me how
many people were like,
I don't support your lifestyle.
There's something
messed up about that.
Close-minded comments that
the queer community gets
from straight
people all the time,
and yet they turn
around and spew it
at someone who is
different than them.
Clearly, navigating the world
of sexuals when you're asexual
could be tough.
And I like that the film gives
a voice to those stories.
One part of the film that I
really enjoyed, but also wish
had been made a
little more clear
is the difference between
a romantic orientation
and sexual orientation.
Asexuals make the
distinction between the two
to accommodate the
fact that they still
need love and partnership
in their lives.
And I think that the
idea that romantic desire
and sexual desire are
different, but often overlapping
is something
beneficial to people
of all sexual orientations.
In the film, they interview
romantically oriented
asexuals to talk about how
it's 100% possible to have
an intimate, romantic
partner that you
don't have sexual attraction to.
So from a scientific
perspective,
asexuality is
really interesting.
In the film, they talk
about a study debunking
the idea that asexuals have
an underlying sexual trauma
or mental illness.
Just like some of
the first studies
that were done on
homosexuality, actually.
Everyone thought
that they were crazy.
Turns out, asexuals
aren't any different
from the average person.
Could it be that asexuality
is an evolutionary response
to overpopulation?
Could it be hormonal?
I mean, we know that
asexuality naturally
occurs in some
animals in the wild.
So we're hoping to catch up
with David Jay, himself, soon
and to talk about this end
of the sexual spectrum.
So I'll keep you posted on that.
And if you want to
watch (A)sexual,
you can watch it for free
on Netflix by visiting
netflix.com/dnews.
And, hey, let me
know what you think
I should watch next down
in the comments below.
Thanks for joining me, friends.
I'll see you next time!